decades of democratic political rule in
Chicago have led to the second city slow
crumbling from the inside so could faith
be part of its renewal a minister in
Chicago just opened a 3,000 seat mega
church in the middle of the city and he
wants his church to be a sanctuary from
his and a safe haven from the allures of
crime and violence but can faith in this
church succeed where government has
failed a lot of liberals will doubt that
but joining us now from Chicago has
passed a Horace Smith pastor thanks for
joining us you know they're thinking
about this today when I was reading
about you there are a lot of churches in
Chicago in Chicago and I got father
Pfleger with that st. Sabinas I'm not a
big fan of his but he has his church I
got Reverend right right is he still
kicking around you got a lot of churches
a lot of people trying they've been
unable to stem the violence so far so
how is yours gonna be different well I
don't think we're unique at all I think
that what we're doing is doing the part
that we should do where we are my
argument is this that you're right there
not only lies in Chicago there have
Corbitt million churches in America but
the question is to the church itself are
we really doing what we should be doing
and make a difference and that's the key
we cannot turn things around by
ourselves but where we're located and
what we're doing can be meaningful and
impactful if we really represent what we
preach about and then put our money
where our mouth is I think you'll see a
difference so every church must look at
it its own something say what are we
doing are we really doing the work we're
called to do by Christ are we doing
something that's more of a social impact
thing that just won't work yeah I've
noticed that and have come some friends
of mine have remarked about some some
mega churches seem more like it's
performance art then than it is about
Christ the Almighty our Christian
purpose and so forth that's fun and it's
fun to have people onstage and dancing
and electric guitars and all that and
that's great praise the Lord that the
mentoring the what you need with these
especially these young boys who many of
them are fatherless have no
all models just talked about this and
they did earlier right that's I mean
that's the case that you know I'm not
against the what you call the pop and
the in the kind of the pool for young
people nothing wrong with that you do
something to attract people that's okay
but once they are attracted you must
have real programmatic things that
really hit at the heart of the matter
and it begins with our own example the
leaders of the church the generation
when we just opened this church it's not
a new church we've been 102 years but is
its theme was crossing over with
multiple generations what we're saying
is that there's a responsibility of each
generation to the other and in many ways
I think in my generation and the one
that pieces to me in some way we have
really failed these young people so we
have almost blamed the victims we put
them in an environment that's negative
that's scarce of resources and their
pastor pastor isn't and without family
without a family unit especially a mom
and a dad if possible a lot of single
women doing great you know good heroic
work right without a father it's hard no
you could mean I'm a I'm very very very
privileged I'm very blessed but it's a
lot of kids who have rudderless they
have nowhere to turn and they go to the
gangbangers and they go to all these
influences and they can sell drugs
easily make a quick buck and then
suddenly they found themselves in prison
that's that mayor of Chicago under
Democrat leadership sorry yeah but the
church can make that difference you've
calculate correctly without a father I
grew up my mother died when I was very
young ten years of age of six of us but
my father stood up my father was the
role model so I'm going to work everyday
as a cab driver then as a policeman he
modeled for me not only my fuel and he
demanded of me I need a minute of me
yeah no voice in my house I was directed
by my father but the church but the
church can become that the church has to
step in where there's a lack and again
remember ship those kind of things and
say hey we can be your father I can be
whatever you don't have and make a
difference pastor I want to come to your
church next time I'm in Chicago is that
well I love you to come and watch it
would be great I'm coming to hang to do
that I'm looking forward to that thank
you so much for joining us I knew he had
a great dedicated dad I just knew it